j'en ai marre là depuis un an on
stigmatise les gilets jaunes on se
stigmatise les gens qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner et on stigmatise les gens
qui ne veulent plus de Macron et
stigmatiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est chez les foules en fait ça fait
deux ans que c'est épidémie dure et à
chaque fois on arrive à repousser les
limites des mesures liberticides pardon
on parle souvent de dictature si ça
c'est pas une dictature qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est horrible et ne faisons pas
les choquer comme si ça n'arriverait
jamais en France parce que déjà ça
pourrait arriver première chose et
deuxième chose rappelez-vous quand on en
était à sortir des attestations pour
prendre notre chien bah désolé c'était
un peu cette arme moi je trouve ça
choquant et je ne comprends pas qu'on en
soit là deux ans après le covid c'est
horrible tu nous apprend pas clasher la
Chine est une dictature non mais bon
c'est des mesures que les mesures qu'on
a vécues en France il y a deux ans on
les avait vu en Chine quelques mois
avant donc ça fait peur c'est
complètement désaccord 23000 cas par
jour ils ont vécu le départ de la
pandémie sont traumatisés et là ils
prennent des mesures que je salue bien
sûr que c'est difficile ils ont divisé
la
faut arrêter et bien pour ça que tu es
vivant c'est insupportable mais non en
fait par la fenêtre combien de jours moi
je ferai quoi d'être vivant si c'est
pour essayer de confiné toute ta vie
excusez-moi on a une anisette pour le
petit chat
il nous manque il nous cache des choses
là-bas déjà Shanghai c'était au départ
c'était le covid 0 contrairement à nous
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont confiné des
pays entier comme l'Australie et tout ça
nous alors il y a eu plein d'erreurs il
y a eu plein d'injonctions
contradictoires mais malgré tout je
trouve qu'on a quand même mieux gérer le
truc à Shanghai ou c'est juste une folie
et là pour le coup une vraie dictature
sanitaire ouais non mais attendez vous
croyez que la Chine est stupide vous
croyez que la Chine fait n'importe quoi
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu vous avez
l'air de moi entre Guillaume Genton qui
compare la Chine et la France qui
compare la vie d'un chien et la vie d'un
être humain je pense que vous avez perdu
totalement la raison il resterait
tranquille merci
qui sont les Français vous faites honte
à la fois
il est 20h Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le
Pen sont qualifiés pour le second tour
leur était plutôt à qui faut-il faire
barrage plutôt que pour qui faut-il
voter et oui car pour une majorité
française ni Emmanuel Macron ni Marine
Le Pen ne leur convient on n'a pas vu le
danger venir mais non je suis ravi de
rencontrer Myriam et tout mais très
sympa tu vois je pense exceptionnel je
dirais même mais je pense que tu il faut
qu'on reste français dans ce qu'on a de
mieux en nous il faut arrêter de jouer
avec le feu voilà c'est Marine Le Pen
fait une campagne exceptionnelle et elle
a trouvé le curseur pour se mettre au
niveau des Français mais après faut pas
oublier un prénom c'est Marine Le
capitalise là-dessus mais elle a un nom
de famille et c'est Le Pen il faut
arrêter de dire que Le Pen c'est normal
Le Pen c'est pas normal Le Pen c'est un
parti qui a été créé avec des nazis
c'est l'histoire de ce pays faut arrêter
de dire que Jean Moulin est Le Pen c'est
la même chose je dis pas que Macron a
fait un bon mandat loin de là je suis de
confession musulmane croyez moi j'ai
vécu pour le coup un mandat avec
Schiappa Darmanin et Blanquer qui hors
sol jamais on a autant parlé de l'islam
et autant de ministres pour le coup un
peu un peu amateur on surfait sur cette
vague là et le en même temps ça marche
pour tout sauf sur le respect des gens
en fait il Yassine je pense que tu
restes sur quelque chose d'avant quand
tu dis ok c'est Marine mais elle
s'appelle Le Pen attention ce n'est pas
son père comme toi tu tu es pas tes
parents en fait on n'est pas pareil et
c'est bien pour ça qu'elle a un peu
coupé avec son père parce que lui
c'était lui elle c'est quelque chose
d'autre tu vois que quand tu la regardes
que quand tu l'écoutes elle propose
vraiment quelque chose elle a travaillé
elle a une forme de bienveillance
il faut que je te liste donc les trucs
je te dis juste aujourd'hui les gens la
loi du aujourd'hui les gens ont le droit
de voter mais absolument aujourd'hui
qu'Emmanuel Macron qui a fait son top
puisqu'il a fait 5 ans il avait 5 ans
pour nous montrer ce qu'il pouvait faire
aujourd'hui à la sortie le bilan c'est
que plus de 60% des Français ne veulent
pas reconduire et pourtant les gens
n'osent pas parce qu'il y a des gens
comme toi qui disent surtout pas
l'extrême droite
le rassemblement national elle a bien
changé parce que tout le monde peut
évoluer
de la tribune des sportifs qu'ils ont
fait aujourd'hui tout plein de sportifs
qui ont dit tout sauf Marine Le Pen moi
ce que tu réponds à ça une présidente
femme voilà une présidente femme
j'aimerais bien voilà une maman des
Français quelqu'un qui qui rassemble qui
protège avec une sensibilité de femmes
on sait très bien que les hommes il
parle beaucoup ils font pas tout le
temps on sait bien que les femmes c'est
des mamans c'est une maman qui fait des
choses et les femmes on peut les femmes
les femmes et l'argument des femmes je
te le dis juste amicalement parce qu'on
se connaît tu ne peux pas dire à des
gens que Marine Le Pen c'est la mère de
la France c'est pas dire à des gens que
Marine Le Pen c'est le diable hein
incroyable juste parce qu'elle a un
autre famille mais tu es en train de
donner je te le dis pourquoi le droit de
les gens aujourd'hui ils profitent de ce
no man's land en ce moment pour se dire
l'extrême droite c'est normal
tu crois Delphine Delphine aussi
voit que Marine Le Pen a des chats euh
qu'elle aime la nature moi ça me plaît
elle est humaine et quand même
des chats l'idée de dire j'en veux à
Macron c'est possible je le reconnais la
séquence que vous avez montré c'est
quand même la preuve que il y a des
reproches mais le fait d'en arriver au
point de se dire et ben je fous le chaos
division mais tu es le premier qui fait
que de parler en fonction du prisme de
la religion ou est-ce que vous ne
comprenez pas ce qui va y avoir un
troisième tour et qui a des gens
aujourd'hui qui sont racistes dans ce
pays qui veulent jouer l'élection dans
la rue et on envoie quoi comme signaux
c'est que dorénavant toute personne qui
est élu elle est légitime mais les amis
les seuls endroits on est légitime à
100% c'est les dictatures africaines ou
en Amérique du Sud tout président d'une
démocratie heureusement à une opposition
allez les chéris cache investigation sur
McDonald's êtes-vous choqué par les
révélations ou bien croyez vous
révélations c'est la question qui avait
demandé croyez-vous aux révélations de
cache investigation sur McDonald's
première découverte le contrat de
travail il est de 15 heures par semaine
c'est carrément illégal la durée
minimale de travail et du salarié à
temps partiel est fixé à 24 heures par
semaine l'assistante administratif à la
solution il suffit de faire croire que
ces Rebecca qui demandent ainsi petit
contrat et que l'employeur lui accorde
gentiment une dérogation
un courrier à côté une idée c'est pas de
mentir cette juste de justifier qu'on
n'est pas faim plus gros contrat d'abord
c'est un documentaire qui est anglais
sur McDo c'est dommage parce qu'on s'en
prend à une seule marque on aurait pu
étudier un secteur on aurait pu regarder
aussi ce qui se passe chez les
concurrents de McDo moi j'aime pas
l'idée de stigmatiser un acteur et pas
un secteur même s'il y a évidemment des
choses à dire sur ce secteur on ne
découvre rien avec ce reportage et c'est
d'autant plus gênant que Elise Lucet
avait personnellement incarné un plan
média à la veille de ce reportage et
elle s'était comportée d'abord non pas
comme journaliste mais comme une donnée
leçon en expliquant qu'être une bonne
mère c'était ne pas amener ses enfants à
Disneyland et pas chez McDo bien moi je
trouve qu'elle va trop loin et qu'elle
dépasse au fond le rôle qui est le sien
à savoir faire partager aux Français une
information
à chaque fois sur ça moi je trouve que
c'est très bien ce qu'elle fait
son travail elle a trouvé un créneau
mais derrière elle met des milliers et
des milliers d'emplois en danger ça
c'est un problème là qui me dérange oui
alors je suis pas d'accord avec vous
mais avec Florian parce que vous dites
ça embauche plein de gens notamment des
jeunes et dans quelles conditions Cyril
des faux contrats de travail qui sont
partisans en caméra cachée c'est à dire
qu'on leur fait signer des contrats de
15 heures qu'on a pas le droit et on
leur on leur fait mentir par courrier
vous rendez compte si demain si demain
là McDo et tous les McDo ferme en France
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte du
nombre de gens qui vont être au chômage
et du nombre de gens qui vont galérer
derrièreont pas ils feront peut-être
moins de bénéfices en faisant signer des
contrats de travail légaux Cyril on
espère
moi je ne comprends pas que le service
public tolère ce genre d'émission à
charge et malhonnête concrètement
comment ça se passe ils se mettent en
conférence de rédaction ils disent moi
alors qui on va défoncer aujourd'hui
McDo il faut un reportage que à charge
et c'est très facile journalistiquement
vous faites des séquences à charge vous
dites les contrats sont pas en règle et
cetera c'est faux et pour moi c'est
intolérable c'est indignes du service
public et ça c'est trop facile moi aussi
je vais chez McDo c'est pas le problème
le problème c'est que les gens qui nous
servent chez McDo sont exploités
utilisés et virer et c'est ce que montre
le reportage
aux États-Unis en France partout c'est
du vrai bon boulot arrêtez Guillaume
c'est la réussite quelque chose qui est
de au fond de donner un rendez-vous
régulier aux Français en misant sur
l'émotion c'est-à-dire elle cherche pas
à faire réfléchir les gens elle cherche
à désigner des bons et des méchants
parce que elle sait que c'est ce qui va
susciter l'engagement ce qui va faire
parler d'elle dans les médias et sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc c'est un très
bon business je pense que ce
documentaire il est celui qui a coûté le
moins cher de l'histoire de première
ligne parce qu'ils ont pompé massivement
tout ce qui était disponible et donc je
ne vois pas en quoi il apporte quoi que
ce soit au débat public
je refuse de donner ma voix à Emmanuel
Macron hier qui venait lui répondre sur
notre plateau appelant à faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen moi j'ai jamais je mettrai
un bulletin Le Pen un échange durant
lequel Delphine Wespiser a pris position
en faveur de la candidate du
rassemblement national elle a une forme
de bienveillance on sait bien que les
femmes c'est des mamans c'est une maman
qui fait des choses alors Marine Le Pen
une maman des Français comprenez-vous la
polémique après les propos de Delphine
Wespiser hier dans TPMP alors les
sportifs ils ont le droit de dire on
vote Macron telle personne a le droit de
dire moi je vote Macron et on n'aurait
pas le droit de dire je vote Marine Le
Pen on recommence les erreurs on
reditabolise marine Le Pen c'est
ahurissant en quoi ce serait choquant en
quoi ce serait choquant de dire avec ces
mots à elle on en pense qu'on veut mais
en quoi ce serait choquant de dire moi
j'ai envie que ce ne soit plus manuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen jusqu'à preuve
du contraire elle est deuxième au
premier tour elle a fait une super
campagne moi je ne partage pas du tout
ces idées mais on va pas au straciser
Marine Le Pen à travers Delphine 2
secondes est-ce que vous pensez est-ce
qu'il y en a un qui pense ici que si
elle avait dit hier ben moi je vais
voter Macron parce que c'est un peu
notre papa à tous est-ce qu'on ferait
cette couleur
c'est des idées que je partage pas et je
pense que toi tu es fier de dire je vote
pour Emmanuel Macron
j'ai voté Emmanuel Macron il a passé une
super journée grâce à toi je sais pas
j'espère bien mais encore une fois je
pense qu'elle a elle a tout à fait le
droit et dans notre pays on devrait
avoir le droit de dire bah moi j'aime
bien Marine Le Pen parce que je trouve
qu'elle dit ça c'est pas mon avis et
mais tu as le droit je trouve de le dire
et tu l'as fait après sur le sur la
forme je suis d'accord que dire que
c'est la mère de la nation que ça
pourrait devenir en fait j'ai dit parce
qu'on est dans une société de patriarcat
pourquoi pas maintenant changer puis
être sur quelque chose ou c'est les
femmes qui prennent parce qu'en fait
c'est un tsunami tu es une ancienne Miss
France tu es une chroniqueuse dans une
émission très populaire aujourd'hui
comme l'a dit très justement Gilles à
part en gros les artistes qui disent on
va te Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ça passe ou
les sportifs disent on vote pour Macron
et ça passe et pourquoi ça passe mieux
non mais parce qu'en fait c'est nouveau
dans la sphère médiatique aujourd'hui
les gens connus ne se sont jamais
positionnés pour Marine Le Pen oh non
mais on a témoins
les plus belles pensées j'ai lu des
choses qui qui conviennent donc je te le
reproche absolument pas je dis juste au
contraire que tu as eu le courage de
dire à la télévision devant tout le
monde bah moi je voterai pour Marine Le
Pen j'en ai marre là depuis un an on
stigmatise les gilets jaunes on se
digmatise les gens qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner et on se stigmatise les
gens qui ne veulent plus de Macron et
incroyable stigmatise elle aussi parce
que donc
en revanche qui est gênant et je suis
désolé c'est ça aussi la polémique ce
sont les arguments dire Marine Le Pen je
vais voter pour elle parce que c'est une
gentille maman elle a des petits chatons
tout mignons désolé c'est pas un
argument qui tient la route elle-même
depuis des années une opération de
dédiabolisation et on relève au second
plan le fait que c'est un parti qui oui
et clivant qui lui a des opinions qui
sont problématiques notamment sur les
femmes voilées et on met au premier plan
c'est une gentille femme qui a des
chatons à ce moment-là moi je veux dire
parce qu'il a un labrador et qu'il a des
followers sur Instagram
[Musique]
pas d'agitation continuons notre
conférence une évacuation musclée
rapidement contestée sur les réseaux
pourtant Marine Le Pen se justifie sur
les policiers de Monsieur Darmanin il
faut s'adresser à Monsieur Darmanin
parce que moi j'y suis pour rien sur
Twitter le ministre de l'Intérieur lui a
donc répondu ayez plutôt l'honnêteté de
dire que l'individu qui traîne la
manifestante sur le sol est un membre de
votre service d'ordre privé ce soir
Pauline la militante qui a été
violemment exclu d'une conférence de
presse de Marine Le Pen réagit en
exclusivité dans TPMP vous avez infiltré
cette conférence de presse vous êtes
fait passer pour des journalistes de la
chaîne RT alors moi je me suis fait
passer pour une
journaliste d'une radio étudiante qui
n'existe pas mais on a été accrédité
pour cette radio étudiante qui n'existe
pas alors le bras là c'est quelqu'un de
la sécurité de Marine Le Pen le SP je
sais pas quoi enfin en tout cas lui il
me l'a dit comment Protection Sécurité
lui me l'a dit parce qu'on a parlé après
c'est lui c'est celui qui me traîne
est-ce qu'il est sympa je sais pas moi
il a voulu il a voulu m'enfermé dans les
toilettes donc là j'ai un peu peur et
j'ai dit non en fait vous allez pas me
mettre dans les toilettes mais donc lui
il m'a tiré voilà ce monsieur là
d'accord
la personne qui m'a fait mal un peu et
qui s'est jeté sur moi je sais pas qui
c'est
je vous le dis il y a quelqu'un qui
m'écrit et qui connaît vraiment nulle
voilà elle est plaquée au sol par un
policier du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
assure la protection de Marine Le Pen
voilà elle est avec protection de marine
et t'assurer donc par c'est ce que vous
avez pas un policier du ministère
d'intérieur elle est ensuite évacuée à
l'extérieur par le service d'ordre du RN
et la police ensemble conjointement
voilà c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé ces images de te traîner au sol
franchement moi je suis pas du tout pour
ça mais j'aimerais juste te demander
dans ce cœur tu as mis Marine Le Pen et
Poutine mais tu aurais pu mettre parce
que des serrages de mains il y en a eu
plusieurs tu aurais pu mettre Macron et
Poutine tu aurais pu mettre un président
alors Macron
en fait le parti de Macron n'est pas
financé par la Russie et par ailleurs
moi jamais jamais tu ne m'entendras
défendre le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron moi
je suis militante écologiste et élu
écologiste et je sais la catastrophe
vous avez peur des restrictions de
liberté mais est-ce que vous pensez pas
que là l'année qui s'est qui s'est
écoulé on était en plein dans les
restrictions de liberté je suis d'accord
avec donc voilà donc en fait ce qu'il
explique c'est que si on teste
aussi
quelque chose d'autre
allez pour le vaccin ou pas Marine Le
Pen alors comment faire la question
c'est l'obligation vaccinale mais la
question c'est l'obligation maximale
qui a dit aux gens fausses vacciner il y
aura bien une suite après on peut dire
aux gens fausses vacciner on n'est pas
obligé de leur interdire d'aller au
restaurant à l'intérieur
[Musique]
à peine libérer de sa tutelle la star
américaine Britney Spears révèle être
enceinte
elle est enceinte de son troisième
enfant j'ai de 40 ans et déjà maman de
deux enfants elle a annoncé la grande
nouvelle à ses fans sur Instagram j'ai
fait un test de grossesse et ben
j'attends bébé elle-même surprise elle
évoque la possibilité d'avoir des
jumeaux une nouvelle mode qui touche
déjà plusieurs stars de plus de 40 ans
comme Céline Dion et ballon Goria ou
encore Marion Cotillard de son père
c'est vrai qu'elle est libérée et elle
avait livré deux enfants de 15 ans et 16
ans elle en a jamais eu la garde donc
enfin il va pouvoir peut-être avoir un
enfant mentalement pourquoi pas
il y a plein de gens qui accusent son
nouveau mari SMS gris de profiter d'elle
parce qu'il a 12 ans de moins parce
qu'il était complètement inconnu avant
de sortir avec elle et parce qu'elle a
une fortune de 60 millions donc il y a
plein de gens qui pensent que c'est une
fortune de 60 minutes ce qui est pas
énorme elle est à 250 millions les mecs
on parle de quoi
250 elle a 60 millions d'euros quand
même et surtout elle
a pas pété du tout qui vous a donné la
parole excusez-moi
non mais elle a pas pu en profiter elle
avait son père qui lui mettait qu'il la
mettait sous tutelle il a obligé à
garder un stérilet c'est-à-dire que vous
pouvez même pas faire d'enfants vous
imaginez c'est de la torture
psychologique enfin nous on a grandi
avec Britney on est ravi qu'elle fasse
un enfant non mais c'est vrai que la
formule de fortune de Britney je savais
pas c'était à 250 millions de dollars au
moment de la tutelle aujourd'hui il en
reste 60 à la quasiment plus rien faire
il y en a c'est 600 millions c'est très
peu par rapport Bieber c'est 400
millions aujourd'hui à peu près d'euros
c'est c'est à 60 millions c'est beaucoup
on fait un enfant il a tout gagné là ça
fait longtemps qu'ils sont ensemble
les stars qui font plus rien Whitney
Houston quand elle est morte il y avait
18 millions d'euros de patrimoine non et
oui il y avait plus rien
non mais tu vois ce que je veux dire
Daniel Moreau elle est à 28 sester
un enfant à 40 ans Castaldi toi
elle avait 42 ans et vous enfin alors
moi je suis pas du tout dans l'ambiance
biberon couchette toute sa couche
de 20 ans c'est voilà c'est plus du tout
là-dedans
ah moi oui bien sûr
non mais vous pouvez en avoir un
deuxième ou un troisième à 40 ans mais
elle en a pas encore c'est pas pareil
quand tu as déjà lancé
le forcément envie de te retrouver
voilà Daniel vous et vous moi Daniel je
suis chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]